[Music]
Hey there, I'm pharmacist Ben and I am
so proud and honored to be talking to
this gentleman sitting by my side here,
Dr. Wallik. I've known him for going on
15 years. I got a tape in the mail like
a lot of folks, dead doctors don't lie
back in the mid 90s and then uh I had
the incredible opportunity of getting to
see Dr. Wallik and since then he never
ceases to me to amaze me and I'm really
really excited to get to not only for me
to be getting to talk to him but also
for you guys to get to hear what Dr.
Wallak has to say. So with that Doc
Wallak thank you. Well thank you
appreciate you. Good to good to see you
and good to be here with you. Why don't
you tell the listeners a little bit
about how you started you got a great
story about u how you started to get
involved with nut with nutrition as a
farm boy. how you noticed uh things with
the animals and how you had a personal
connection with nutritional
supplementation, how it worked out for
you. Well, I'd like to do that
pharmacist Ben, but I tell you what,
before we do that, how about you telling
us a little bit about pharmacist Ben?
About pharmacist Ben. All right. Well,
pharmacist Ben started uh started his
pharmacy career in 1986. And uh in
pharmacy school, a lot of a lot of
people don't realize this, but we study
a little bit about nutrition, but we
study nutrition in terms of how
nutrients are medicines. and we study
how diseases are deficiency diseases. So
this is one of the reasons why I
connected with you so well because this
is your message. We're not sick, we're
starving. Many of the things that we
consider to be diseases, heart disease,
diabetes, the things we die from in this
country are really nutritional
deficiencies at their core. And what I
like to tell people is at the point of
death itself, we don't die of what it
says on our death certificate. We die
because some tissue system somewhere,
some organ system somewhere is not being
fed. So we literally die of nutritional
deficiencies. And in pharmacy school, I
was studying how vitamin A was connected
to night vitamin A deficiency was
connected to night blindness and vitamin
C deficiency is connected to to
circulatory problems. And on the other
hand, I was studying how prescription
drugs were toxic and how they had side
effects. I remember one time we watched
a movie on beta blockers. These are
drugs that stop the heart from working
in order to lower blood pressure. And
this was a movie put out by Ayers for
their new drug indal. I was going to
revolutionize the the the uh uh the
hypertension business. And I remember
the movie was an hour long, 15 minutes
about how revolutionary their drug was
and 45 minutes was some guy reading the
side effects of the new drug. 45
minutes, I'm telling you, reading the
side effects. So, I got the idea that we
got a real big problem in this country
in terms of healthcare. And the more I
studied, the more I got into it, the
more I realized that if we could just
get nutrients in the hands of people, if
we could just get people to start taking
nutritional supplementation, we could do
a lot of good. And so I started
practicing in my pharmacy using
essential fatty acids to help people
with their skin, essential fatty acids
to help women with their menstrual
cramps, B vitamins to help lower blood
pressure. And lo and behold, as I'm sure
you know, the results were tremendous.
So, from the get-go almost, I realized
as a young pharmacist that we could be
using nutritional supplements instead of
using medicines and we could be helping
a heck of a lot more people and we could
be saving a lot of money on top of that.
Then when I heard your message, I was
all over it. I got that tape in the mail
that doctors don't lie and I was like,
who is this guy? And I listened to it
and I listened to it and I got to tell
you, I stole some of your ideas and I
went out and I started talking to folks
using some of your ideas. And then uh
one day I was working out in the gym and
I met a guy and we were talking. I said,
"You you have to hear this tape, Dead
Doctors Don't Lie." I said, "Oh my god,
I know Dr. Wallik." And turns out that
this guy knew uh our mutual friend,
Robert, Robert Snook. And uh long story
short, he took me to one of your talks.
I listened to one of your talks and uh I
was a I was a believer and a follower.
And that's that's how I got involved
with uh that's how I got involved with
Youngevity and that's how I got involved
with you. So uh in any case uh now I
want to talk about you and your story is
very interesting how you started uh with
nutritional supplementation. I started
it was already the 1980s. So it was all
there were already people who were who
were understanding the vitamin C and the
B complex and essential fatty acids and
minerals were very important. But when
you were working with nutrients we're
talking about the 1940s. Vitamins were
only really discovered 20 years before
by mainstream science. So for you to get
on board you had to be quite the
visionary. I wonder if you could maybe
tell the tell the viewers a little bit
about how what what went through your
synapses to make you realize, hey,
there's something out there that we
could be using to help take care of what
people are considering diseases. People
are considering genetics, genetic
maladies, people are considering birth
defects, but really are nothing more
than nutritional deficiencies. Well, it
actually started when I was four years
old. Uh I had a disease that would be
called today Tourette's syndrome. They
didn't have a name for it back then, but
it's Tourette's syndrome. And I had
facial ticks and you know, blink my eyes
and I'd get facial cramps. And it
progressed. It got worse every year. By
the time I was nine years old, I'd go
into a tetany and fall over and um my
friends, my peers, my age uh group
classmates would say I was possessed and
they could bump me around and give me a
bear hug and cause me to go into this
tetany. And so I started complaining to
my mom and she took me to an eye doctor
for some reason who's an MD eye doctor
and they examined me and said u can't
find anything wrong with him except he's
got very long eyelashes are hitting his
glasses curling back and tickling his
eyeballs. That's what's setting this
off. They thought that was what he tried
to say that was causing the tent. That's
right. And so I'm 9 years old and I'm
not buying it. I said, "No, that can't
be my eyelashes tickling my eyeballs.
It's that's too much of a systemic
problem." I didn't use the word
systemic, but my whole body was
affected. So, I didn't believe it was
just my eyes. So, the next morning I
went to the library in school and um uh
I went and found a nurse's health
handbook and looked for long eyelashes
and eyelid twitches and that kind of
stuff and couldn't find anything. So, I
just went in the index and just started
a and I got down to cramps. I said,
"Well, maybe it's a cramp." Because I
was playing sports and uh at 9 years old
and I said, "Well, I've heard of leg
cramps and things." And so I um looked
it up in the book Cramps and said it was
a calcium deficiency. Well, before the
bus would pick me up to go to school
every morning, I would feed our calves
we were going to take to the auction
this little bag full of alalfa pellets,
but it had a little analysis tag on it
and just I'd read the analysis tag. It
talked about protein and fiber and
calcium. And so I went home that day
after school, ran right to the barn,
started eating these calf pellets.
Tastes like sawdust, but hey, I had a
problem. I was going to get rid of it.
Next morning I threw the Cheerios out to
the chickens. I filled that cereal bowl
up with a calf pelts, put milk on it. I
did that for three days. By the third
day is gone forever. Forever. Wow. And
of course, I've been taking the 90s
essential nutrients twice a day since I
was 9 years old. 64 years. So, what went
through your head as a young boy when
you take you're taking this these things
that are for the calves and all of a
sudden you're this movement disorder
that must have been traumatic for you as
a kid. What went through your head this
like a you thought it was a miracle?
Well, I thought it was one of those
Eureka moments because I I understood
something that doctors didn't. I
recognized immediately that doctors
didn't know anything about nutrition
when I was nine years old. And I don't
know if that was a divine appointment or
what, but I I do know that I realized
then at nine years of age that doctors
really didn't know much about that sort
of thing. And I didn't realize that I
was going to get into it as a
profession, but I knew that I could help
myself and I could help my mom and my
grandmom and that kind of stuff. And so
I began to do more reading on nutrition
and I began to mix um chicken food with
the calf pellets and dog food. And I was
making my own little meatloaf and
things. And as a nine-year-old boy, as a
nine-year-old boy, by the time I was 18,
I really had it figured out. And went to
agricultural school at the University of
Missouri, halfway through a school,
applied for veterary school, got
accepted, finished my egg degree. Two
years into my veterary degree, actually
found the first case of a ma mass die-
off from pollution. got it written up in
international journals and veterary
journals and that started my um path
between nutrition and finding a mass
die- off from pollution and actually get
written it up. It was the first one in
America. Okay. I want to hear about this
mass die off. That sounds interesting.
Well, um halfway through a school I
applied for veterary school. I just as a
lark I figured I'm going to start
practicing. So when I graduate a school,
I'll apply and I'll know what I'm doing.
Well, because I was working my way
through school feeding the the
university's beef herd and the dairy
herd and milking the cows, the herdsman
gave me very good recommendations and so
I got in as a a sophomore a student.
They said, "Well, you really don't have
to finish a school if you don't want to,
but I wanted to." So, by the time I
finished a school, I'm a sophomore
veterary student and um now I'm a
graduate student. Well, that just so
happens in 1962 all the professors took
off and left the graduate students in
charge of all the services. And of
course, pathology services, farmers
would bring in dead animals. You had to
find out what they died from and so on.
Or you have to look at biopsies from
surgery of small animals. Well, this one
day this farmer brings in 50 lambs and
he says had 500 lambs die the night
before. I said, "Anybody else around?"
He said, "No, just me. I just
he started doing autopsies on him. As
soon as I cut that first lamb open, I
knew what it was because the blood that
came out onto the wool looked like
chocolate milk, which is met hemoglobin.
Well, is met hemoglobin met hemoglobin.
So, it's a darkened it's an oxidized
hemoglobin, a dark hemoglobin. It looks
exactly like chocolate milk. Wow.
Instead of red or purple or black and um
it's only caused by one thing and that
is nitrate poisoning. It's the only
thing that will cause it. So, I knew
immediately it was a nitrate poisoning
thing. So, I said, "Uh, did you use
extra fertilizer in your crops or he
said, "No, I didn't." I said, "Well, I
need a water sample and I need some
bring it in tomorrow." And uh as I'm
finishing the autopsies, every one of
these lambs, instead of having thyroid
glands the size of a limema bean, one
lobe on each side, each one the size of
a limema bean, each one was the size of
a plum. And when you cut through it,
instead of being like a beet, you know,
firm and and crisp, it when you cut
through it, it was like blackberry jam.
So rotten and decay. Yes. Yes. And so I
knew that he these lambs and every one
of them had the same problem. These were
six-month old lamb. They had twoinch
wool. They were beautiful. I put 10 of
them in my freezer and ate them. Right
there. Nothing wrong with them except
that they had goer and met and met hemog
globin. And it turns out that the
neighbor had bought some fertilizer to
uh high nitrate fertilizer to get more
corn for bang for his buck and it was
uphill and rained and got down this
guy's well. Well, uh did all the the
chemistry on the water, the feed, the
lamb's blood and their liver and
everything. And what happened was why
did 500 of them die in one night? And so
I figured, okay, it has to do with
metabolism and temperature and stuff.
Well, it was December. And in Missouri,
in December, you can have a day like
today, it could be 50 degrees in
December in Missouri. And it's been like
42, 50, 36, 38. Well, the night they all
died, it was 19 degrees. It just dropped
to 19 degrees. They all died of
hypothermia. They metabolism was off.
They their thyroid gland wasn't working,
so they couldn't maintain their body
temperature. 500 lambs died of
hypothermia in one night. Wrote that up.
got it published in the National Journal
of the American Veterary Medical
Association and also international
journals and it became instantly known
as a student worldwide. You're 22 at the
time. 22. Yeah. That's awesome. So, I
think it's really important that people
understand that you have a lot of great
incredible wisdom and intuition when it
comes to nutrition and chemistry, but it
comes from actually working with the
tissue hands-on. you actually saw what
these nutritional deficiencies do to
chem to the tissue to the organ systems
of the body. And I think people need to
recognize this is not just this is not
just theory and this is not just book
learning. This is actually hands-on
understanding about what nutrition does
to the body in terms of its organ the
body's organ structure and the body's
cell structure and the body's tissue
structure. That's super important.
There's not a lot of people out there
who are pathologists or have pathology
background and a nutritional background
as well in a physician and a veterary.
That's right. That's right. That's
right. Well, the thing that that
followed up from that was uh I was
working with Marlon Perkins as a kid,
you know, during high school and he got
me a job doing Wild Kingdom. Wild
Kingdom Mutual Omaha. Marlon Perkins.
Yep. And he got me a job in Africa on
the white rhino um u project which had
to do with saving the white rhinos. This
is it was one of those conservation
projects. And I was able to get 200 of
them uh bring them back to the United
States, caught them. And so if you see a
white rhino in a zoo or wild animal
park, it's either one that I caught or
maybe offspring. Well, because of that
paper, Perkins was and this was the time
when pollution was being brought to the
surface by Silent Spring, you know, the
move or the movie Rachel Carson, the
book and so forth. And he he was very
good. He thought, you know, we have all
these animals dying from natural causes
in zoos. Maybe pollution has something
to do with it. kind of like the canary
in the mine concept. Like the old Welsh
coal miners, if the gases got in the
mine, the canaries would drop off the
perch long before the men would die and
they could run out before they blew. So
extinct animals were like a a canary in
the coal mine or animals that were
becoming Exactly. And so he said, "We're
wasting this material. We need to have I
know a guy wall because I'd give him
copies of that paper on the lambs." Oh
wow. So he pulls me back out of Africa
and he made me the chief pathologist in
that project which combined the services
of the Shaw's Botanical Gardens in St.
Louis, the zoo, and the biology
department of Washington University. And
so it was called the center for the
biology of natural system. And make a
long story short, over a period of 12
years, I did over 20,000 autopsies and
over um
17,500 were on over 454 species of zoo
animals, 3,000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to the zoo. And the book
that came out of it um is 1,200 pages.
It's in the Smithsonian Institute as a
national treasure.
Well, they were shipping me all over the
place. What What struck you? What What
What hit you the most out of 12,000
autopsies? That's a lot of tissue.
20,000. That's a lot of tissue you're
looking at. What struck you the most?
What was the most made the the biggest
impression on you from looking at all
that tissue? Well, pharmacist bend the
most profound finding and this was sort
of in the summary of of all there was
like 75 scientific papers that came out
published in international journals. I
mean, this is a big project. National
Institutes of Health, $25 million, which
is a lot of money back then. It's chump
change now, but back then it was a lot
of money for a 24 year old kid, right?
And so,
um, the profound bottom line finding
was, and this was published now, every
animal and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease. That's awesome.
Pollution was kind of a background thing
and in some cases it contributed to it.
Um, and that's those are another long
stories. But they could have handled the
pollution if they were nutritionally
solid. Exactly. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's beautiful. So now this is 1962.
1962. This is 1962. So So take us
forward because you didn't start to
become wellknown and the dead doctors
don't lie. Didn't didn't hit for another
1993. Till 1993. So So take us forward
from 1962 through the 60s. What's going
through your head as you're seeing that
there's this problem with nutritional
deficiencies? And and you must it must
have hit you that hey we're not we're we
got a big problem here. We well we knew
it was a big problem and um when I was
in Africa for that two years working on
the white rhino project I was still
studying nutrition because I wanted to
know what elephants were eating where
they were getting their minerals where
they were getting their vitamins. We
were testing water and testing the
leaves on the trees and the bark that
they were eating so forth and writing
papers from that too and so forth. And
when it came back and began to do these
autopsies, they would send me, the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation would send
me to different facilities because some
facilities had whales and some didn't.
Some facilities had walruses and some
had gorillas and didn't. And so they
wanted me to do autopsies or draw blood
samples or whatever I had to do to get
as many species involved in this
project. Well, they actually after um
the time at the St. zoo. They sent me to
the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago because
they had whales and they had the shed
aquarium with dolphins and and they had
the the Brookfield Zoo and the Lincoln
Park Zoo. So, the number of species went
way up. And I I was walking into this
office and I'm unpacking and there's two
biologists there who are getting ready
to go on an expedition into
Alaska to catch some wild arctic foxes.
And say, "Oh, that sounds like an
interesting project. Why are you doing
that?" They said, "Well, we have a a
pair of Arctic foxes here at the zoo, at
the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago, and they
must have some terrible gene because
Arctic foxes normally have 10 to 12 kits
in their litter. And they were only
having three to five kits, and they're
always born with this birth defect." So,
they have this terrible genetic problem.
So, we want to get some wild genes and
bring that in and reconfigure the genes
and so forth. They said, "Well, tell me
about it." They said, "Well, five years
earlier, you know, the babies were born
with neural tube defects. And four years
earlier, they were born with no limbs.
Three years earlier, they're born with
no diaphragm. Um, so they all suffocated
to death." All different things. All
different things. Every year is a
different thing. And then the last year
they had cleft pallets. And I said,
"Well, it's not genetic." Because it' be
the same birth effect. It' be like the
same birth effect, year after year one
gene, it'll be the same problem.
Exactly. He says, "What are you feeding
them? Ground up horse meat." And they
said, "Well, are you giving them any
vitamins?" No, because they're meat
eaters. We just give them meat. And so I
knew what the problem was right away. So
I said, "Okay, I'll tell you what. Since
you're the guys are leaving this week,
why don't you get them off a display?
They're imperfect." I played to their
beliefs, right? So I said, "They're
imperfect specimens anyway. Give them to
me. Let me kind of work on them and do
some test on them." And they were happy
with that. They brought them up there.
And when they left, I went to the
grocery store and bought some dog food
for toy dogs. And I gave it to the
foxes. Within a couple of months, they
had a normal litter of 12 babies. So I
did the thing that a a good farmer would
do. I inbred them, right? I bred the
mother to the sons, the father to the
daughters, the brother to the sisters.
And um by doing that, I had 300 foxes
very quickly, right? And then I inbred
them. And I inbred them. By the time
three years went by, I had over a couple
of thousand foxes. They were in the
reptile house, the bird house, the
administration, healthy foxes. All
perfectly healthy. Not a single defect
in any of them because they're all
getting dog food, which is perfect.
Well, I think what you're talking about
here is so interesting because this is
the early This is the middle 60s now.
We're talking this is the early 60s.
Yeah. Well, today the cutting edge in
science and in genetics is not genetics
at all. It's epigenetics.
Today, the cutting edge in science and
in genetics is not genetics at all. It's
epigenetics. Correct. So, what you were
doing 30 years ago was epigenetics. Was
epigenetics. I wonder if you could tell
the folks a little bit about the whole
idea of epigenetics. what how
epigenetics relates to genetics and how
nutrition relates to epigenetics. Well,
you have to appreciate how the medical
mind thinks. Pharmacist Ben, you know
this being a pharmacist and but for for
our viewers here, the medical mind is
that they get a theory and everything
belongs to that theory. For instance,
back in the days of the cavemen or witch
doctors and shamans, everything was
caused by evil spirits, right? And then
there was alchemist and it had to do
with turning distillation turning lead
into gold and all that kind of stuff and
sprinkling. All you have is a hammer.
Everything looks like a nail. That kind
of thing. Exactly. And then it went into
spontaneous generation because they
didn't know about germs yet. And they
thought that life spontaneously
generated from nothing. And then along
came Van Luenhoke, the Dutch um um he
was actually a spectacle maker. Made
eyeglasses. And he invented the
microscope. Yeah. But he put two lenses
instead of one lens for your right eye,
one eyes for your left eye, he put one
lens on top of the other, made a
compound lens. Yeah. Made a compound
microscope and he looked at pond water.
He sees all these little animals
floating around. He writes it up. Well,
pasture gets he's he's a um a guy who's
working on wine trying to keep it from
going sour and going to vinegar. And
that's came up with pasteurization. He
was studying yeast. Yeah, he was
studying yeast. Exactly. And so um once
he learned that it was a living thing,
he couldn't see it because he didn't
have a microscope. Once he had a
microscope, he could see the little
little yeast buds and budding and
growing. Pastor was a contemporary. Oh,
yeah. Van Luen Hook. Okay. Yep. And um
uh he immediately knew that spontaneous
generation was not the thing. He knew
things were caused by these germs.
That's where the germ theory came from.
And then of course um he was the first
one to actually practically make
vaccines. Although there was a a medical
doctor in England by the name of Jenner
who was involved. Got a small fox.
Exactly. And so um uh
um when you had pasture, he actually had
to he took 25 sheep in the center of
Paris. He set up pens, artificial pens
or temporary pens. He had 25 sheep that
he vaccinated for anthrax. He had 25
sheep he didn't. He gave anthrax to all
50. And the ones that were vaccinated,
uh 24 of them survived and one died. And
the ones that didn't have vaccinations,
they all died. And so the press was
there and it was everybody agreed that
he knew the answer to anthrax and so the
medical system couldn't argue with it
because the press had already made it a
feat complete right and um then comes
along Mendel and Darwin right and
Darwin's talking about how things evolve
in the Galapagos Islands and he'd see
all these different finches which are
really the same species but they had
different colors and different beaks but
they're the same species and that's
because it took a little adaption in
each of the different islands to survive
the predators and things. That's where
he came up with the theory of evolution
by watching the finches. By watching the
finches, that's where he got that idea.
And he knew there was something being
passed on from one generation because
they could the ones who were successful
had some adaption, right? That was the
word adaption. And the ones that
couldn't adapt got eaten by the
predators. This is the beginnings of the
genetics there. There's something being
passed on, some information passed on
from parent to offspring. Exactly. And
then here's Mendle, who's this monk,
right? Then he's growing peas and he's
studying peas which the monks love to
eat. And he was studying which he could
get the best peas and he learned that
there was something being passed on that
the color of the pea flowers um and the
whether they're wrinkled or smooth or
they're big or they're small and he
could pass on these traits. And so he he
talked about threads and he knew that
something was being passed on. He
literally said threads. He said threads
are being passed on. Threads of life are
being passed on. Carrying information
was his words. Wow. We're talking about
in the early in the early 1800s. Yeah.
And um uh and so that was the beginning
of the genetic theory. Well, along comes
people like Lionus Pauling and Watson
and Crick and they were able to actually
tell you the structure of a chromosome
and so forth and double helix and how
traits like eye color and skin color and
hair color are being passed on and so
forth. The genetics Pauling was in on
the whole genetic thing as well. Well,
he was the first he was actually the
first one. He was actually cheated in my
um he should have actually gotten part
of that Nobel Prize that Watson and
Chris did because he came up with a
helix before Oh yeah. Wow. He proposed
that 10 years before they came along.
They were just in their 20s and he
proposed it 10 years earlier. Wow. But
they were actually able to do it and
then show it. But so he really should
have gotten some part of that Nobel
Prize, but he didn't. But any rate um
then along comes all the genome thing,
right? I know suddenly now genetics is
going to solve everything. Right.
They're just every every time they have
a new theory, it solves everything.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Okay.
And of course the genetic theory was
fought for a long time. Uh just like the
earth is flat theory was tried to be
defended by the holders of that theory
until Columbus came along who was an
ignorant Portuguese um seaman, right?
Said the earth was not flat. No, was
he's the guy sailing out there. He knew
the earth wasn't flat. And so, um, it
comes down to perceptions and what you
know and so forth. They they were
limited. So, any rate,
um,
my revelation, if you will, back when I
was 9 years old, the diseases could be
caused by nutritional deficiency. Kind
of I I learned everything I could about
nutrition. Of course, in agriculture
school, we learned that we could prevent
and cure as many as 900 different
diseases in animals with nutrition that
in medical school, they tell them were
genetic. Did you know that there was a
it was really a nutritional and
epigenetic component that the nutrition
was actually changing the genes? Yes.
Well, now we didn't have the word
epigenetic. Nutrition was changing the
genes though that there the nutrition
lack of nutrition was affecting the
genetics. And now that's a better word,
affecting. Okay. They weren't changing
the genesffecting. Affecting because the
genes are like a factory. The
chromosomes are like a factory. Can you
build any factory without raw materials
or or parts? No. Without labors and
energy? Of course not. No. No. Okay. So
the a gene in a chromosome is the same
way. It's just a blueprint, right? A
gene in a chromosome is just a
blueprint. Nothing else. So you put a
gene in a chromosome in a bucket of
saline. Say, "Okay, come on boys. Go to
work and make something." Ain't nothing
happening. Right. You still need the
gene that makes protein. The blueprint
is just there to make the protein. You
still need the raw materials to make the
protein. That's right. Yeah. And so um
we learned in agricultural school that
we could prevent and cure every disease
you can think of. We can prevent and
cure um well let's see we can prevent
every birth effect. Many of them you
could cure some of them like cleft
pallets a surgical case right and for
instance congestive heart failure the
most common cause of heart disease death
in add it's a deficiency of a single
vitamin. In fact, when I went to the
next thing after the foxes in the
Brookfield Zoo, the shed aquarium there
in Chicago, they called me over and
said, "Hey, we hear you're wanting to do
autopsies on some citations, which are
whales and dolphins and things." Yep.
They said, "Well, we got a freshwater
dolphin here from the Ganges River in
India just died, and we get 10 or 12 of
them every year, and by in the spring,
and by the fall, they're all dead. This
is pretty typical. Why don't you give us
your thoughts? What's happening here?"
So, I go over there and cut that thing
open. First thing I I knew immediately
what it was because the heart of a 300lb
freshwater dolphin is as big as your
fist. This dolphin's heart was as big as
a basketball. He died of congestive
heart failure, which is a deficiency of
a single vitamin. So I said, "Are you
giving these dolphins any vitamins?"
"No, we're feeding them whole fish. They
eat fish, so we just give him whole
fish." I said, "Tell me what species of
fish because there are certain fish in
their tissues. They have an enzyme that
kills that vitamin." You're not talking
about vitamin C.
No. Thimon. Then thinase. There's a
thaminase in the tissue of smelt.
They're feeding because of the size. The
smelt was the perfect food from size
standpoint for these freshwater
dolphins. They were they didn't have any
thamin. They didn't have any thin
because they weren't putting a multiple
and extra thamin in the mouth of those
fish when they fed them to the little
freshwater dolphins. So told them to
change the type of fish they were
feeding them. Give them multiple and
some extra B vitamins with a lot of
thamin. stop the deaths in the
freshwater dolphins that shed aquarium.
And so these are the things I could do
with nutrition. And here's all these
biologists. I mean, these guys are very
skilled, very well trained biologists
when it came to behavior of the animals
and and um their dynamics in captivity
and so on and how they reacted for
territories with one male against the
other, that kind of stuff.
Behavioralist. Yeah, exactly. But they
weren't biochemists. They were
biologists, but they weren't
biochemists. They were biologists, but
they weren't biochemists. And so I could
come in and see something very simple
that I've been studying for 10, 15, 20
years and see it in a heartbeat where
they could look at it and they couldn't
recognize it. Now th is a fascinating
vitamin. That's the berry berry vitamin.
Exactly. That's the vitamin that they
were given with Tell the story about the
chickens and the and the rice
polishings. Well, berry berry is very
interesting disease. Uh sailors of
course used to die from this by the
thousands every year and as they went
around the world and and their sea
voyages were longer and longer and
longer um more and more sailors I mean
twothirds of the crew would be dead from
berry berry by the time they came home
particularly as as time went along
because they demanded modern food and
modern food to them meant polished rice
white rice instead of brown rice because
that's what rich people ate and so they
wanted that as part of their demand. If
we're going to go on this long sea
voyage we want polished rice. Okay. And
twothirds of the crew would die from
Barry Berry. Well, first of all, they
get a dementia called Corsoff syndrome.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Which is caused by a
thamin deficiency. And then they get
congestive heart failure. It's like a
cure for Corsica syndrome is th I cure
people in a week. Yeah. Yeah. That's
amazing, right? But I give them 26,000
times the minimum daily requirement. I
hedge my bet. Right. Okay. So any rate
um uh just all these diseases that um
these Japanese naval surgeons were
really the first ones to recognize
there's some problem here when they fed
these sailors this polished rice. But
the admiral te you know the big guys up
there the admiral say well listen these
guys are demanding this this has nothing
to do with it's got to be some bug. They
thought it was a bug. What year are we
talking here? We're talking about the
late 1700s. Wow. Okay. in the 18th
century and
um and Europeans get the credit for
discovering it but it was really these
Japanese non it was a Polish chemist
Kaiser Funk. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Who came
up was his name. Yeah. But well he he
actually identified it but before that
the Japanese naval surgeons knew there
was something in there. They knew there
was something in in the brand of the
rice in the brown covering the hole in
the rice was could prevent and reverse
that disease. And they would all die of
congestive heart failure but they would
all go crazy. They'd lose their minds.
Corso syndrome. Yeah. Before they die.
Alcohol. People who drink alcohol that
deactivates thamin somehow. Well, sure.
Well, it it Well, alcohol is a liquid
sugar and it makes thin used for
metabolizing the alcohol. And so when
you take in sugar or alcohol, yeah, it
makes a deficiency worse. Talk about ADD
maybe. How about B1 deficiency?
Subclinical B1 deficiency for kids who
have ADD, they're eating sugar. Maybe th
maybe maybe they don't need rolin. Maybe
they need something like like thamin or
how about subclinical issues? You know,
we talked about conject the big things
like congestive heart failure, Barry
Berry, but what what are the impacts of
subclinical thamin deficiency where
maybe they're just not getting enough
thamin? What are the impacts on our
kids? And okay, well, that's a good one.
Let's talk about ADD, ADHD, autism. Back
when I was a kid, there was no such
thing as those things, right? Um, in the
year
um two, let's see, 1980. In 1980, it was
one out of um 150,000 kids had autism.
In the year 2000, it's one out of
150. Today, it's one out of 88 is the
new It just came out last week. Wow. One
out of 88 now has autism. Wow. And
basically, when I was a kid, all four of
my grandparents were from Eastern
Europe. They were beet farmers and beef
farmers. And so for breakfast, I would
have cheese and beets and beef and eggs.
And no Cheerios, no cornflakes. No, not
when I was a little baby. Nope. And um
uh we didn't have those types of
diseases. Well, here comes now um 20
years later, kids are being fed on these
box cereals full of
carbohydrates with sugar on it. They're
getting apple juice, right? How can you
build a brain which is twothirds by
weight, 75% by weight is cholesterol and
good fats? Okay. And so now all they're
getting is carbohydrates and sugar and
they're going crazy, right? Not only
they're deficient, but it's costing them
nutrients to process all that stuff.
Exactly. So it makes the nutritional
deficiencies worse. Even worse. Right.
Right. And so simply I take kids that
haven't spoken in 11 years. You start
feeding them age. You get them on the
90s essential nutrients which is what we
feed animals. The 90 essential
nutrients, 60 minerals, 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, three essential
fatty acids. And after 11 years of not
speaking, I have kids who can read the
Bible out loud in churches. That's
awesome. And you know what, Doc? I say
this on my radio show all the time. I
say you're gonna think it's a miracle,
but it's not a miracle. This is the way
the body works because you give the body
what it needs and it will respond. This
amazing system, this amazing divine
system. You touched on cholesterol. I
definitely want to talk about
cholesterol. But before I get to that,
my favorite mineral, you know, in the
world of nutrition, you get a you get
favorites, right? You probably have your
favorites, and I know one of them that's
one of my personal favorites, I know is
one of yours is selenium. So tell us a
little bit about selenium, this
incredible, incredible mineral and some
of the things that you can use it for.
And I want you to uh give place special
attention on how selenium is involved
with the thyroid, how selenium is
involved with diabetes and all the
different things that you can use with
this incredible mineral that by the way
is active in microgram quantities, the
tiniest of quantities. Maybe touch on
that a little bit. Okay, as you say,
selenium is one of those wonderful trace
minerals um which is an essential
nutrient. We need it. We can't live
without it. And it's a has many
functions. It's a structural mineral um
when it comes to chromosomes, right?
Epigetics. Epigenetics. We'll get into
that, right? But it's a structural piece
in the actual normal double helix.
It's is it one of the fingers that you
were talking about? It's one of the
metallic fingers that keeps this double
helix of the chromosome in the in the
proper distance of each other. There's a
little strut there. In the middle of
these struts, there's all these
different minerals and selenium is one
of them. Wow. So the the helix itself is
an incredibly organized structure and
every little component of it is key. The
distance that the the nucleotides are
from each other. All that is tightly
tightly regulated and minerals like
selenium are involved in making sure
that this structure stays intact. That's
what the fingers are.
Exactly. And when you have a deficiency
of selenium, many things happen in the
biochemical level. Uh you can't recycle
glutathione which is one of the most
potent antioxidants made by the body
maybe. Mhm. And it's used to protect you
from cancer and fend off inflammation
your arteries so you don't get clogged
arteries and that kind of stuff. But if
you don't have enough selenium, you use
one molecule of glutathione and it it
sort of deactivates. But when you have
selenium, you can recycle that one
molecule of glutathione a thousand
times. That's awesome. Is that's very
awesome. And then it protects your brain
from MS. When you have MS, you have a
terrible, terrible um selenium
deficiency because it allows the free
radical damage to the myel and the white
matter of the brain again and you get
these lesions the brain about the size
of a limema bean that cause MS. So
supplementing with selenium can prevent
or reverse MS. Wow. Along with the 90
essential nutrient can't not by itself.
That's right. So 200 micrograms to 400
micrograms. What do you Well, I like to
be a little heavy-handed. 600. I like to
be a little heavy-handed. A milligram.
Yeah. A milligram, thousand microgram.
When you have these disease, you need
to, you know, you need to use a bigger
hammer, right? Okay. HIV. You can
prevent HIV from mutating to AIDS by
supplementing with selenium. Wow. One
milligram a day. What's the difference
between Arthur Ash, the great black um
tennis player, and Magic Johnson, the
great black basketball player. One is
dead, one's alive, one supplementing
with Seline, one didn't. Is that what
that's what Magic Johnson's doing? Oh,
that's interesting. Now, how about just
even just a common cold or just like flu
and that kind of I'm getting there.
Okay, getting there. That's very good.
You're on top of it. Um, but I also,
it's one of these things. It's they
actually discovered Dr. Ghart Scher, a
grand man. He's the guy who discovered
that um, selenium is an essential
nutrient back in 1957. They didn't
consider it essential back then. No,
they they considered a poison. Exactly.
They thought it was a poison. Even
medical doctors today still think it's a
poison, but it's actually was discovered
to be an essential nutrient. And the
disease he was looking at was liver
necrosis, the death of your liver. If
you survived death of your liver, you
got cerosis of the liver, right? And
this is all caused by not drinking
because 99% of the people who get liver
cerosis never took a drink of alcohol in
their life. It's a selenium deficiency.
Wow. I get people off the liver
transplant list all the time. Wow. Wow.
Wow. That's a big problem today.
Non-alcoholic fatty liver disease.
That's a huge problem. fatty liver,
primary scosing colangitis, liver
cerosis. I've had people, pharmacists
been who've had 32 liver operations at
Harvard Medical School. Their livers are
the size of an Oreo cookie and I rebuild
them in two months to a normal liver.
Just using the 90 central nutrients and
extra selenium, right? Okay. And then
there's cataracts are caused by a
selenium deficiency and free radical
damage. Eating fried foods, free radical
damage to the lens of the eye and no
selenium to protect it. And then you get
cardiammyopathy, heart disease. I've
done one. Kishan syndrome. Kishan
syndrome. Y I've done 1,200 autopsies on
kids under the age of 10 in Kishan
Province, China.
1,200 autopsies. Nobody else has ever
done that. They're all deficient.
They're all deficient insul ins and
selenium. And partially because of our
work there in China, every school kid
when you go to kindergarten, they get a
multiple and a capsule of selenium.
We've wiped out cardiopathy heart
disease in children in China. That's
awesome. Is that awesome? That's
awesome. Now, there's a isn't there an
animal coralate to this Keshan syndrome?
Yes. Slenium deficiency. Yes. In sheep.
Well, in every animal you can name,
there's that there's a correlation. But
in pigs, they call it mulbury heart
disease. In sheep, they call it stiff
lamb disease because when they had heart
disease, they kind of walk with archback
and they're kind of stiff. And in
calves, cattle, they call it white
muscle disease because when you cut
through the heart, instead of having
this beautiful kind of reddish purple
heart,
uh it looks like um a good perch muscle.
It's white. So they call it white muscle
disease. And you can prevent it with um
little bit of well with the 90 essential
nutrients plus extra selenium. If they
get it and they survive the first heart
attack or you catch it with just a a ar
ahythmias in their heart, you give them
the selenium, it goes away. How about
for the thyroid? The thyroid gland of
course there's actually a syndrome
called Wilson syndrome. The question is
how many nutrients does your thyroid
require? Well, probably not. All 90.
Yeah. Now, if you ask a physician,
they'll say iodine because it's part of
the structure of the thyroxine hormone.
But that's only the part of the
structure, but for the thyroid gland to
work, it needs all 90. Duh, right? And
so, um, a lot of times when they look at
the T3, T4, the TA, TSH, and all that
kind of stuff. Really, what they're
looking for is iodine
levels. And so, you can be perfect. They
say, "Well, we don't know why you're
having all these symptoms of thyroid
disease because yeah, we give them
iodine and nothing changes." Well,
that's because it's a selenium
deficiency. That's interesting. Well,
selenium is involved in the in the
hormone as well as part of the
structure, but actually is even equally
important. It's part of the process of
making the hormone. Okay? And as is
copper and everything else. And then of
course it's necessary for the health of
your muscles.
Mustardrophe has caused musculardrophy
is a selenium deficiency. Now a fellow
by the name of Marvin Robini who grew up
Amish and he went in and became a Navy
Seal going from the Amish world to Navy
Seal. He comes back after 20 years in in
the SEALs. He goes back a worldly man
now and he sees all these kids dying of
mustard drophy in the Amish community.
And so I go there and I say well this is
what we see in calves that have mustard
dusty or white muscle disease and it's a
slim deficiency. So we went to Purdue
University and sure enough in Indiana
wherever these kids are that have
mustard destrophy there's always a
selenium deficiency in the soil. So we
started giving them the 90 cents of
nutrients giving them extra selenium and
the mustard drophy goes away in a couple
of weeks. Even if they've been in
wheelchairs for years we get them out of
the wheelchairs and go play basketball.
So we send all this information to Jerry
Lewis. This is a gospel truth story now.
We send all this information to Jerry
Lewis. Five years it went crazy
positive. He loves it. Yeah. I said now
Jerry we're not asking for money. We
already know the cause, prevention, and
cure of muscular drophy in kids. We
already know this. And we just think
it's appropriate that we offered you the
opportunity to make the news release
because you're
muscular. You are they're Jerry's kids,
right? So, you're the obvious guy to
make the news release if you want to. If
you say no, we'll just we'll be happy,
but at least my conscience is okay
because I've given you the opportunity.
He gets excited. He takes it to the
medical
committee in the Mus Foundation. They
fire Jerry Lewis. That's why Jerry Lewis
has not been on the teleathon for the
last two years. Oh, that's an amazing
story. And they sent him on a cruise.
They actually bought him a ticket to
say, "We have a non-disclosure contract
with you, Jerry. You can lose
everything. We'll sue you for everything
if you bring this up." And so, we're
sending you on a cruise. Go enjoy
yourself. And don't bring it up again.
We want you away from here. Wow. When
we're having this teleathon this year,
because everybody's going to say, "Well,
where's Jerry?"
Cruz. It's over with. He's That's a
great story. And so they fired Jerry
Lewis because we discovered the cause
and cure of and I knew what it was for a
long time but until Marvin Rob came back
from being a Navy Seal and introduced me
to the Amish community I didn't have
access to those kids. So selenium must
for uh for muscular district. But I
think your point's well taken that you
have to have the entire mighty 90. These
things are specific for disease states
but the entire millu of the body has to
be nutriated. That's right. Because
everything kind of works together. Yeah.
And if you you have to have the
metabolism to be able to repair
yourself. You have to have the
metabolism to operate just in life. And
so to think you can cherrypick one
nutrient. This is one of the bad things
the medical system does. Alipathic
nutrition I call it. Yes. Where you just
use a nutrient like it's one kind of
drug, one kind of disease, one Exactly.
Use a nutrient as a drug. Yeah. instead
of using the whole I I liken it to
grandma's recipe for um an angel food
cake for instance and she dies and she
leaves her secret recipe to her favorite
granddaughter, right? But the
granddaughter doesn't like some of the
ingredients. She said, "I really don't
like eggs because of cholesterol
theory." Right. It's not going to be the
same cake. And so you leave the the eggs
out and all you get is a angel food
crepe. Yeah. You change your cake,
right? Because all the ingredients work
together. Exactly. And the Mighty 90
works together the same way. Yeah. All
right. So, there's so many things I want
to talk about, but I don't think any
conversation with Dr. Wallik would be
complete without talking about colloidal
minerals. Okay. Okay. And uh first of
all, there seems to be a lot of
misunderstanding. People don't really
understand what exactly a colloidal
mineral is. And and I think it's it's it
makes sense that there'd be
misunderstandings. You know, Albert
Einstein and and some of the great
physicists, they studied colloidal
colloidal solutions, colloidal
suspensions. They were so fascinated
with how these things work and how they
interact with the water and the
electrical nature of all that. Why why
don't you tell folks first of all tell
folks how you discovered the power of
colloidal minerals and exactly what are
colloidal minerals and why are they so
special and so effective. Okay. Well uh
thank you pharmacist Ben. Um back again
in the late 80s I was working with some
of the alternative cancer um hospitals
in Mexico. they invited me to come do
some things with them. And um that's a
long story how I got there, but that's
another time. But any rate, uh I one of
the problems I had was getting all the
nutrients that people needed because
most people wouldn't eat calf pellets
and dog food and things like that.
Right. Right. And so I had to find a way
because in human supplies there's not it
was very difficult to get things and so
I needed a source of some really weird
trace elements and rare earths okay like
gallium yrium neodymium preodium the
body needs you get disease if you don't
have them most doctors you ask them
about those deficiencies rare earth
europium you ask them about those things
doctors look at you like a deer in the
headlight they've never heard of them
right and so I was looking for those
things well Here at one of these
alternative cancer hospitals is a little
gallon glass jug and it says take an
ounce of this with every meal. And I
taste it. Woo! It it kind of shrunk wrap
your lips over your teeth. It was very
tart right minerals. Yep. And um so I
said, "What is this?" He said, "Well,
this this stuff that comes out of the
mountains and has all these different
minerals in it." So I took it to Dr.
Schrower, University of California. I
said, "Anal analyze it." And it had 77
minerals in it, including all these
really weird trace minerals and rare
earths. exactly what I was looking
for to make this what turned out now to
be the Alex Pack. Right. Right. You got
it. Right. But that was back in 1985. I
had been looking for something, but it
was so expensive. Have all the tra you
were looking for something that would
have all those trace minerals and the
rare earth. And if we were to put it
together one by one by one, it would
cost $1,000 an hour to take that stuff,
right? And so it's too expensive. So
here's a natural source and it had
everything in there in optimal amounts.
I mean, I really got excited because I
said, "Now I've got the tool that I can
bring this to the general public."
Right. Wow. Well, a colloid is actually
a mineral that's in suspension rather
than in solution. So, it doesn't
dissolve. It hangs. It hangs in there.
Now, how does that do that? You've heard
of Brownian movement, right? Well, all
these particles are the same charge and
so they repel each other and so they
stay in suspension by their own energy
because they're repelling each other
like little magnets. That's awesome.
Isn't that awesome? Yeah. High. This is
a highly electrically charged solution.
That's right. It's like a magnetic
solution, but they're all the same
charge, right? That's the secret.
They're all the same charge. That's how
they're repelling. That's right.
Brownian and movement. And they've knew
about that for a long time. But you're
talking about one nutrient, one mineral,
but here's one with 77 minerals in
there. And there's this um it's almost
like a liquid alloy of 77 minerals. Wow.
And for instance, if you take a
solution, a liter of a solution, you can
maximize whatever you can get in there.
You get
985 or 989 milligrams. That's all you
can get into the solution. There's only
so much room in between the water water
molecules. Now, in a suspension, I can
get
36,000 milligrams. How do you do that?
Ah, kidneys, right? I can get 36,000
milligrams. Well, when you taste that,
that'll, you know, that'll shred the
enamel off your teeth. is so acid. So I
had to cut it down to 19,000 milligrams.
But now we're getting up into the dosage
rates. You don't have to drink seven
gallons a day. I had to concentrate it
down. All these little mechanical
factors I had to deal with. I had to
concentrate it enough to where a human
being could take a couple ounces and get
enough. Nobody's going to drink seven
gallons a day to get enough. Right. But
these are highly concentrated
suspensions. Yes. But I had to
concentrate them more. Wow. Right. See?
And so this is perfect for me because I
could get 19,000 milligrams in a liter,
600 mill 600
um I could get 600 milligrams in an
ounce. That's amazing. That's amazing,
right? That's amazing. And so, but in a
solution, I could only get 30
milligrams. And so, how what accounts
for that difference then? Well, in a
suspension, it doesn't matter how much
room there is between the water
molecules because these guys are in
there keeping each other in suspension
all the time. They never settle out.
They're self- suspending. They're self-
suspending. They never settle out. Wow.
It's a it's a perpetual motion machine.
That's So you're when you you're
actually drinking an electrical
electrical energy. You're drinking
magnetism of a sorts. Yeah. So you're
drinking a magnetic solution. So would
you say that the effect on the body is
amps up the magnetic energy? Well, if
you look at the heart for instance,
which is an electrical thing, right? Um
when people start getting palpitations
they um are having electrical conduction
problem. So you give them selenium in a
in a colloidal form. Problem solved.
Wow. Okay. And so uh it's that simple.
But any rate then I was able to make
liquids. Of course I'm think I'm
considered the father of liquid
supplementation at that level. And the
initial product we had was just what we
called plant minerals. I remember that.
Yeah. 77 plant minerals uh which contain
all 60 essential minerals in optimal
amounts 1 ounce per 100 pounds of body
weight and most people are deficient in
minerals. So just taking those minerals
made an enormous positive difference in
people's lives. And then people were
saying well what multiple do I take with
it? So I had to come up with a multiple
and then you think it's tricky to add
all the vitamins and amino acids and and
things to it. Now I tried adding the
fatty acid turned it into soap. I'm sure
it became a solid. You can't add you
can't add fatty acid, but it's it's a
miracle that you could add all that
other stuff in there. That was that's
some amazing formulations. And let me
tell you something. I formulate for a
living. And the formulations that you
guys have, Young Jeby's come up with
some formulations that are absolutely
stupendous. And it started off with that
bottle of minerals, that bottle of
minerals, that bottle of minerals. So,
we just kept adding things to it. Of
course, we run into the thing like
turning into soap and we had bottles
exploding and stuff. And so, in the
early days, it was quite adventurous.
And then of course right now we have in
the Alex pack which you can buy by
itself or part of the Alex pack. I like
the Alex because you got a complete
thing is the Beyond Tangerine has 245
nutrients in it. That's a stupendous
product. That's a wild stupendous
product. That's it has 300 milligrams of
these minerals per serving. It has lots
of B vitamins. Well, mega doses. Mega
doses. Right. Right. And then it has 115
super juices. This this we're not
talking about a V8 here, right? We're
talking B or a V 115. That's amazing.
V15. Yeah. V115, not V8. Plus 1,000
milligrams of vitamin C plus copper.
Plus selenium. Well, plus all 60 plus
gluc is there glucosamine. I think it
is. No, that's a that's an amazing
amazing product. If people don't do
anything but that, they're going to
notice dramatic results. Oh, huge. Huge.
And of course, kids like it because it
tastes good. Tastes great. And then for
absorption, that's another thing. You
know, in pharmacy school, we study
delivery. That's one of the main things
we study is delivery. And they tell you
if you want to deliver things in the
body and you don't want to use a
suppository and you don't want to use an
injection drink the stuff and that is
that was actually in addition to the
colloidal minerals the nature of the
colloids the fact that it was in in a
way you could drink it and you would get
instant absorption is so important
because people has digestive problems
everybody has digestive problems
bypassing digestive problem liquids go
ahead well I'll answer that question in
a second but what we did was even I
thought more fun we take these colloids
which in themselves are very absorbable
Right. And then we tremendously
absorbable, very absorbable compared to
even solutions. And so then we turn it
into a coffee crystal type technology.
Now talk about that. Well, coffee
crystals are not actually like you're
making an instant drink. Okay. Because
what we did was turn it into a brewed
thing which has all these juices and
vitamins and minerals and amino acids in
it. We made these huge solutions and
then we freeze-dried it and they turned
into crystals. You just add water and
suddenly now became it become it
rehydrates becomes the original
suspension again. Is that what makes the
BTT so special? It's like freeze-dried.
Yes. Do you remember that commercial
they used to have for the freeze-dried
coffee? That whole uh that's that's the
coffee crystals. Yeah, it's the same
idea. And so we take a colloid and we
turn it into the coffee crystal
technology. So it recalloid it becomes a
colloid again. It becomes a colloid
again. So the BTT is it's a it's a
colloidal suspension. Well, it's a
conution and then we put it into
resuspension. But when people
reconstitute it, it becomes a suspension
again. It becomes a suspension again.
So, they're actually drinking this
colloidal liquid again. Exactly. Even
though it's it's port it's portable and
you can carry it around and and like you
can take it on the plane with you. You
can take it on the plane. That's great.
All right. So, uh cholesterol. Okay. I
want to talk about cholesterol. Statin
drugs. Hundreds of millions of
prescriptions are filled for statin
drugs every year. Everybody's terrified
of cholesterol. Somebody here was asking
about eating eggs and people don't want
to eat eggs. They don't want to eat the
yolk and eggs and there's so much
misunderstandings about cholesterol.
Please tell our listeners tell tell the
viewers a little bit about uh first of
all what cholesterol is, why it's so
important and then uh okay how you can
how you can make sure that you have
enough cholesterol in your body using
dietary strategies. Well, first of all,
cholesterol is an important part of our
human structure. Every cell wall is like
30% cholesterol, right? Okay. every cell
wall, if the trillions and trillions of
cells in your body, every one of them,
30% or more, in some cases 60% of the
cell wall is cholesterol. So you can't
make you can't make cells without the
stuff. That's right. And cells won't
work without it. They die without it.
And then um 75% of your brain weight,
the white matter of your brain, the
myelin cholesterol is cholesterol. Okay?
If you don't have enough cholesterol,
guess what? You get Alzheimer's disease.
It's a physician cause disease for
lowering our cholesterol. then you can't
make sex hormones. Testosterone,
estrogen, progesterone, and adrenal
hormones are all steroid hormones. 95%
by weight is cholesterol. Cholesterol.
Vitamin D3 is cholesterol. Seven hydroxy
25 cholesterol. Right. Right. It's
cortisol. Cholesterol hormone. Exactly.
So, adrenal hormones, all these things
are cholesterol. So, you don't have
enough cholesterol, you get erectile
dysfunction, you get menopause, you get
adrenal exhaustion, you get Alzheimer's
disease, all of it. All of it. How can
this thing, this beautiful chemical,
this beautiful molecule be so demonized
in our culture? It's amazing to me.
Well, here's why. Because again,
biologists don't know anything about
chemistry, right? Doctors don't know
anything about nutrition, right? So
that's a maximum. Well, in
1971, after having done 20,000
autopsies, I wrote a paper which
compared the plugged arteries in vegans
versus plugged arteries in meat eaters.
looking at this cholesterol series,
right? Well, the vegans are eating what
the grains and well, grains, vegetables,
fruits, and nuts. And guess who had the
worst clogged arteries? Vegans, right?
Because of the cholesterol meat. Well,
there was a little bit of cholesterol in
the in the scarring of the arteries. And
that's why they in their brains, they
thought it was a cholesterol, but there
was turbulence in there. And the body's
putting cholesterol. They're trying to
smooth it out. you know, like these
non-stick pans that the the the body's
response is to throw cholesterol at
trying to smooth out the turbulence.
Now, when people eat meat, is there
cholesterol in steak? Is there actually
cholesterol mo even after it's cooked
and after it's processed? As long as you
don't burn it. Okay. Now, but here's
here's the beauty of that study. 1971,
20,000 autopsy. They come out and this
is published in an international Danish
um pathology journal, active
pathological, translated into six
languages. This went around. Millions of
doctors, millions of pathologists all
over the world read this. Now, they all
laughed at me because they're saying,
"Well, Wallik must be sniffing glue
because cholesterol causes heart
disease." Well, guess what? Um, where
were vegans getting their cholesterol?
They're not eating meat. They're not
eating eggs. They're making it.
The
oils in the grains are
oxidizing because they were stored
improperly.
So now and then they stir fry in extra
extra extra virgin virgin virgin olive
oil. You turn those oils into trans
fatty acids and heterosyclic means right
by heating them. They eat a lot of salad
dressings. Where's the cholesterol
coming from? The from the body makes a
little bit as a sort of um again a
protective device. Protective device
kind of like this non-stick pan again.
Right. Uhhuh. Okay. But it's it came
from your own body making it's
upregulating your the body's
manufacturing system of cholesterol.
Yeah. But it's it's it's infantestally
small. It wasn't even a factor. But they
picked that's the only strange thing
that was in there, right? And so they
picked that out for some reason. And
they came up with these statin drugs to
lower cholesterol. Well, here comes now
41 years
later. The FDA in Science News just a
couple of weeks ago came out and said,
"Uhoh, Houston, we have a problem."
They put out new warnings on statin
drugs saying diabetes increases your
risk of diabetes by 50%. Increases your
risk of Alzheimer disease by 100%.
That's amazing. If you go on a
cholesterol-restricted diet and you take
cholesterol-lowering drugs, satin drugs,
you will get Alzheimer disease. Okay?
And I said that in 1971 and they all
take cholesterol for to make neurons.
You must eat eggs. See, egg is a perfect
food. Uh you start out with a a chick on
that egg the size of a lentil as thick
as a piece of paper. The diameter of a
lentil, right? I mean, we're talking
about three or four millimeters in
diameter, onetenth of a millimeter
thick. That's the chick. And there's the
yolk and the white. That's all food for
the chick. In 21 days of incubation, you
have a chick with a beating heart and
lungs and legs and all the muscles and
feathers and skin and eyes and brain.
All from that little egg. All from that
little egg. And so it's a perfect food.
Yeah. And so if you want to keep your
brains, you want to have a great sex
life, you want to don't, you know, you
want to have your adrenal glands are
happy, you don't want to have menopause,
you don't want electron erectile
dysfunction, you better be eating six to
10 to 12. I eat a minimum of eight eggs
a day. I try for 12 every day. Where
else can you get? What other foods would
you recommend? Uh, eat the chicken skin,
throw the chicken away. Just don't eat
it fried. Okay. Uh, you can eat fish. Uh
yeah, you get a little bit of
cholesterol actually in salmon in the
fat underneath the the salmon skin. Uh
you can get it from red meat. Uh you can
get it from
um
um lard and butter. You get a little bit
of cholesterol and butter. What do you
think about what nutrients would you use
with your cholesterol? Any particular
vitamin E or essential fat? Oh, sure.
You have to take the 90 essential
nutrients which includes vitamin E and
we're talking about selenium and vitamin
A. All these things are um antioxidants
in their own right. Now, vitamin A, why
did they call it vitamin A? Because it
was the first one discovered when it was
discovered over 4,000 years ago by the
Egyptians. They could get rid of night
blindness, which we know is caused by
vitamin A deficiency by giving people
extracts of of liver. Liver, they they'd
squeeze liver, get the juice out of the
liver, give it to you, and night
blindness would go away. Vitamin A is a
stupendously important vitamin as well.
How about for the immune system? Vitamin
A for the immune system, of course,
because it's an antioxidant. Yeah. It
helps protect you from free radicals and
also helps your immune system fight
against um organisms, transmitted
organisms like bacteria and viruses and
fungus and yeast and all kinds of stuff.
So, every one of the 90 essential
nutrients is important. They're called
essential nutrients. They're not
optional nutrients. The word essential,
that's what that means. Now, uh real
quick, I wonder if you could touch upon
the digestive system. We got 80 million
Americans with digestive problems. One
out of three Americans are dealing with
some kind of digestive issue. When we
know with liquid nutrients, you can
bypass a lot of that. But what would you
recommend for folks in terms of not
essential nutrients necessarily, but
accessory nutrients that people can use
to support digestive wellness? Okay.
Well, first of all, the old theory used
to be you are what you eat. Right.
Right. That's not right. It's what you
absorb. You are what you absorb. Very
good. You are what you absorb.
And so when you pick the right number,
when you said 30% of Americans have a
terrible digestive problem, Mayo Clinic
came out in 2009 and said 30% of
Americans have gluten
intolerance. Now, there's some
communities that eat a lot of grains
because there, you know, for whatever
reason that's well, it's cheap. It's
stored for years in case there's some
eminent disaster, right? We're talking
about the Amish, the Menanites, the
Hutterites, the Mormons, the Seventh Day
Adventists are all vegetarians, eat a
lot of grains. They have 80% gluten
intolerance. H now what that does is you
lose the villi in your small intestines
and you get celacc, you get
diverticulitis, you get um irritable
bowel syndrome, inflammatory bowel
disease, and you don't absorb your
nutrients. You lose 85% ability to
absorb them. So what's 15% of nothing?
Nothing. Very little. Yeah. Right. And
so, uh, the problem we have now is all
these people now are being told to eat
whole grains. And so, there's all this
gluten intolerance happening. So, people
are not absorbing what little nutrition
there might be naturally in the food,
right? And they're not supplementing.
And so, you have to get off of gluten,
you have to supplement properly, and
then 99% of these problems go away.
you're talking about
um when you're talking about diseases
for instance like um oh you have a baby
born with mustard disease cystic
fibrosis cleft pallet they're born deaf
and all this kind of stuff invariably
the mother will be gluten intolerant
because what little nutrients are in the
food she can't absorb them very
efficiently she's got a malnourished
fetus she's got a malnourished fetus wow
it's not genetic oh yeah it's
malnourishment and malnourishment but
here's the thing that gives doctors a
little bit of hope that their theory is
correct. Gluten intolerance is passed on
through cord blood or breast milk. It's
not genetic, but the glutens are passed
on allergens. Well, they're not even
allergens. They're not it's not an
allergy. It's an intolerance. So, in
other words, the the proteins, the
peptides are passed through in the milk
and the the baby becomes intolerant to
it as well. Yes. Exactly. Now, here's
the deal. Nobody's allergic to poison
ivy because there's no pollen involved.
Nobody eats it for salads, but everybody
is intolerant of it. Now, you rub poison
ivy on yourself, you don't get an
allergic reaction. You don't get an
immune reaction. You have a contact
dermatitis, right? The same thing when
you eat gluten and you have a gluten
intolerance, you don't get an allergic
reaction. You get a contact It's a
mechanical issue, would you say? It's a
chemical irritant. You get a you get a
contact entteritis. Uhhuh. Okay. So,
it's not necessarily an allergic
reaction. It is not an allergic
reaction. It's it's still an immune
reaction. No, it's not even an immune
reaction. Is it mechanical? It's a
chemical irritant. Uh-huh. So, gluten is
an irritant. Oh, yeah. It's a contact.
Bakers bakers will get it, too. There's
baker's dermatitis. Oh, yeah. Exactly
the same. Same idea. And so, what you do
is you get these people on glutenfree
diets. Their asthma goes away in two
weeks. It's amazing. And you have a
woman who's had three kids in a row with
musphy. You put her on a gluten-free
diet, you give her the the 90 essentials
of nutrients appropriate for her body
weight, you throw in some extra
selenium, she'll never have another
child with mustard. She can have 10 more
kids, but none of them will have mustard
because it's not genetic. That's
amazing. Now, uh, are there other things
in grains aside from gluten? Gluten gets
all the press, but there's other things
as well. Are there other proteins, other
peptides? Sure, there are allergens. You
can get a wheat allergy, but it's not
necessary to be gluten intolerant.
Uhhuh. Is grain a problematic food in
your opinion? Yes, it is. Because human
beings were never designed to eat grain.
Yeah. Now the animals that do very well
with grain are extra stomachs. They have
four stomachs. So if we have four
stomachs, maybe we could be we'd be able
we have a single stomach and we we don't
have the capacity to handle grains like
like an analopee and a a buffalo, you
know, a buffalo and the horses and
cattle and sheep and goats and all these
animals with four stomachs. There are
they when you look around the world,
other than one-sellled animals, the four
stomach animals are the most universal
farm. They're everywhere on every
continent, every place. There's more
species of ruminant animals than there
are elephants. So, our digestive system
just isn't designed to eat these kinds
of things. That's right. Isn't that
interesting? You know, by Jared Diamond,
right? He wrote a paper called
agriculture was the the worst thing that
ever happened to us in human history.
Something along those lines. But the
idea being that we're not supposed to be
eating these kinds of foods. Germs,
guns, and guns, germs, and steel. Yeah.
Yeah. But the idea is that we're not
supposed to be eating these kinds of
foods. Uh what about gluten-free? What
about gluten-free flowers and
gluten-free grains? What's your take on
those? Well, gluten-free grains are
what? We're talking about millet. Yeah.
Buckwheat, which is not wheat. Quinoa.
Quinoa. And you're looking at rice. You
ever hear the old macrobiotic diet? I
know. I don't know why. Well, during the
60s, the hippies, all those flower
children were running around eating the
macrobiotic diet, which was essentially
a um uh a German cleansing diet that was
made from brown rice and steamed
vegetables. It was only supposed to be
done for two weeks, but they really they
felt good on this stuff, right? And so
they add a little bit of fish to it,
maybe some eggs so you get enough
protein so you could live on forever.
And I mean these people were solving
problems like eczema, asthma, all going
away in this macrobiotic diet. And they
say, "It's the magic of the brown rice."
No, it's because they gave up wheat.
Uhhuh. That's okay. And there was this
Mishio Cuchi who
popularized he's a Korean guy who
popularized the macrobiotic diet had
terminal pulmonary tuberculosis. I mean
his 90% of his lungs were filled up with
tubercal abscesses and he was beyond
hope according to the doctors. Right. He
got on the macrobiotic diet and three
months later he's gluten-free. He's
cured. That's a great story. Now now uh
I don't know if people really recognize
that you are a prolific writer and you
write some great stuff. You write some
great books. And what I like about your
books is how you pull together all these
disparate fields, these disparate
sciences, anthropology and sociology and
history and economics and nutrition and
chemistry and biology. You pull the
whole thing together and you got a great
story and I think it's in Hell's
Kitchen. I'm not sure which one. I think
it might be Hell's Kitchen where you
talk about the the wood ash and that's
just a brilliant story about how people
got the idea that you could actually get
healthy by using ash. And you see
sometimes you'll see ash on in the
ingredient decks or in the nutritional
uh facts on dog food and uh tell us a
little bit about this whole idea of ash
and minerals and how that works in terms
of nutritional uh nutritional power and
nutrition. Sure. Well, this goes back to
the caveman. Was that Hell's Kitchen by
the way? Is that Well, it was in Hell's
Kitchen. There's a little bit of that in
the book Rare Earth Cures. Okay. And
also a little bit in Let's Play Dr. in
Martinez. Oh. Yeah. It's in all of it
because um in the old days, even in the
caveman days, you know, they had fires,
right, for their fuel, right? And um the
cave is going to get filled up with
ashes. So, they had to throw it outside.
It didn't take long to recognize that,
you know, where they were throwing those
ashes, the green stuff, the leaves were
twice as big than where it didn't get.
So, when they started gardens, they
would throw the wood ashes into the
gardens rather than just throw it down
the stream uh or in the recycling bin to
save the earth, right? they put in the
gardens. Well, wood ashes are not ashes.
Wood ashes are really the minerals that
the tree had sucked up out of the
ground. And when you burn the wood for a
fuel, the minerals don't burn. So you
have a powder in the fire pit, the
fireplace, the wood stove. The ash is
the minerals that aren't burning. Yes.
They put them in the garden. So then the
ochre and the tomatoes and the corn and
the sweet potatoes and the beans and
peas and cucumbers suck it all up. Eat
your vegetables, your grains. You got it
that way. You got your minerals in that
fashion. Nobody made the connection yet.
They were using it as a fertilizer, but
they never made the connection. They
were getting minerals from it. They
never did that.
Um,
but when I know the exact moment when
everything changed. It was 3:00 in the
afternoon, Monday, September 4th, 1882,
when Thomas Edison pulled the switch on
the first commercial electric generating
plant. 3:00 in the afternoon, Monday,
September 4th, 1882. He pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
generating plant on Pearl Street in New
York City on the on the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
Brooklyn Bridge. Within 10 years after
that, every city dweller had switched
over to electricity for heating and
cooking.
How many wood ashes? They didn't need
any more wood ash. No, they needed them.
But how many wood ashes were left over
when you cooked and heated with with
electricity? Nothing. Zero. So what did
they do to replace all those minerals
they've been getting for thousands of
years? Nothing. They got sick. They got
sick now for diseases they never heard
of before. Oh, how interesting. So with
electricity? Yeah. It it just displaced
were our source of minerals. That's
interesting. It was sort of a change of
of just like right now. Um, you can't
hardly find a pay phone in an airport
because of cell phones have replaced it.
Newspapers are going away um because all
the little classified ads are going away
because of the of the cell phones and
eBay and all that kind of stuff, right?
Um, so is the postal service going away
because of email?
Okay. Well, the same thing happened when
you had the um uh electric stove come
along. There's no ash anymore. No ash
anymore. But they didn't make up the
difference. Nobody knew to make up the
difference. And so Woodshash has been
when you look at the top and this is
where the book um immortality comes in.
Um we looked at the top 20 longevity
cultures on Earth. We did it through
National Geographic. We looked at we
read 60 years worth of National
Geographics because we knew we'd have to
spend millions of dollars of our
personal money and years and years and
years. Then people would say, "Well,
Wallock, we don't believe this one." And
we'd argue about that one. So we took
everything from the National Geographic,
give them plenty of credit and so forth.
We use their pick of the top 20
longevity cultures who have 40 times
100. We do they have 100y old per 250
population. We have 100 old per 10,000.
Wow. Okay. Which cultures? Well, we're
talking about things like Sardinians,
the Ncoyans in the Pacific coast to
Costa Rica. Really weird places you
never heard.
Okinawans and so Hunzas up in the
Pakistani border with China. Titty
kakas. Yeah. the titty coacos and that
kind of stuff. It really really weird.
All top 20 longevity cultures are third
world cultures. They're they're
illiterate. They have no doctors, no
medical system. They have no
utilities. Glacier milk. What do they
have? Well, I thought that's what it was
in the beginning. But the universal
thing that they picked was they all use
wood for fuel. Ah, and by dumb luck,
pharmacist Ben, by dumb luck, when you
looked at the agricultural schools at
the universities in the countries in
which these cultures exist, by actual
analysis of the land that they grew
their food on and they got the trees
that they use for wood for fuel, they
had 60 minerals or so by dumb luck. By
dumb luck. Yeah, that's great. All
right, we just we talked to our friend
uh Aaron just a few minutes ago, and
he's an amazing amazing testimony to
your to everything you talk about. lost
100 pounds. Everybody wants to lose
weight. Obesity is ridiculous. We're the
number one obese nation in the world.
We're the starving obese. We are It's
crazy what's out there. By uh by 2030,
they estimate 50%. Not overweight, doc.
Obese. Okay. So, how can we use the
mighty 90 to lose some weight?
Especially now with Christmas and and
Thanksgiving is how can folks use the
mighty 90 to lose some weight? Well,
again,
pharmaceut. spend more money for
healthcare than all the nations of the
world combined, yet we're the number one
obese nation in the world. What's going
on here? What that tells you, you don't
have to be too bright to stand back and
say, "How could we be the number one
obese nation world?" What does that say
about the level of understanding of
obesity by our doctors and our
government? They know nothing. Nothing.
Otherwise, we'd be number 204, right?
We'd be the thinnest people on earth and
the healthiest. But we're number one
obesity because they know nothing about
obesity. In their theory, you know what
I'm saying? In their theory, obesity is
caused from lack of exercise and a
disease of excess. You're eating too
much. Right. Because they think that
we're like an oven. They think if you
eat carbohydrates at only 4.5 calories
in calories out that way. Exactly. 4.5
calories per gram as opposed to 9
calories per gram for fat. You can't buy
fat. It's fat-ree, low fat, no fat, but
we're still fat. We're still obese.
Okay. And that's because it is not a
disease of excess. And it's not a
disease of lack of exercise. When you're
obese or even overweight, it's a disease
of deficiency. You're deficient in a
couple of minerals. So, obesity is
actually a deficiency disease. Yes.
Obesity deficiency disease of a couple
of minerals. All right. And the symptom
of the deficiency, these couple of
minerals is the munchies. Ah, so you can
cure the munchies by using these Oh,
yeah. Uh-huh. So, what are the minerals?
Well, I won't tell you yet.
So, I tell everybody what I want to do
is get that book, Hell's Kitchen, and
read the whole story. Okay. So, it's
just a couple of minerals that will take
care of the munchies. Well, it's a well,
there's two minerals that if you have
those a deficient those two minerals,
you're going to be one of these people
who weigh 600, 800, 1,200 lb. But any
mineral deficiency, not vitamin, you can
be a deficient all the vitamins you want
and you won't gain weight. Huh. It's
mineral deficiency. It's a mineral
deficiencies in horses. It's called
cribbing. They chew on the fence, right?
How about pika? Is that what pika is?
PA. Yeah. And little kids will eat dirt
and stuff like that. Y it's caused by a
mineral deficiency only. So when people
have the munchies, their body is in it's
the body's wisdom is let's go get some
minerals and they're trying to trying to
find these minerals. You're driving you
to eat something to find the minerals.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So using the
mighty 90 and using these minerals will
take care of the munchies and take care
of the weight loss. Suddenly now if you
just get on the Alex pack, take the 90
essential nutrients, you'll lose 10, 15,
20 pounds in a month. We see this all
the time. Yeah. Without even thinking.
Yeah. Because suddenly now your portions
are automatically get smaller because
you're tired of throwing food away.
Yeah. And you're not going to eat
between meals. You'll you'll take some
snacks and think, you know, I'm I don't
even know why I took this. I'm not even
really that hungry, but out of habit,
you're doing it. And it doesn't take you
long to figure out I don't need to do
this anymore. So, dieting isn't even
hard once once you get the nutrients
that you need. I wouldn't even use that
term. Yeah. What I would do is talk
about portion control as opposed to
dieting, right? Because you don't even
have to think about portion control
because when the pah and the and the
munchies goes away, portion control is
just sort of self regulating, right?
Now, to speed it up, we have actually
have what we call the Celender FX weight
management system, which has a meal
replacer in it, uh, which is 80 calories
and and no sugar. So, it's great for
diabetics who need to lose weight. It's
only 80 calories. You could have two of
those meals a day. I like to throw in a
couple of eggs, uh, and make it with
water. You're only going to get like a
250 calorie meal. So, two of those is
500 calories. You can have a 300 or 500
calorie meal. You're down below 1,000
calories. And you have all your
nutrients. You have all your nutrients,
right? because you're still going to
take your 90 essential nutrients. You're
going to take your Alex back even though
you've cut your calories, your portion
controls way down here, but you you're
still taking your 90 essential nutrients
and you're going to lose weight. We see
it all the time. In fact, that's the
most dramatic example of how powerful
this stuff is is the weight loss. And
the weight loss isn't even shouldn't
even necessarily be the target of what
you're looking for. That's like an it
just happens. It just happens. It
happens on itself. Now, if somebody
needs to lose 25, 50, 75, 100 pounds or
more, then we throw in what we call
ASAP. I like to add ASAP. Yeah. ASAP is
an acronym for as slim as possible,
right? But I like to say ASAP. ASAP
because it's as slim as possible. As
soon as possible. Yeah. Now. Exactly.
And so, um, what I like to do if you
need to lose 50 pounds or less, you put
one dropper full under your tongue, um,
of this liquid. What it is, it's it's
amino acids, which is the raw material
for your pituitary to make certain
hormones, like growth hormone. No, like
HC. Oh, h Oh, okay. All right. All
right. And so, don't tell anybody. I
won't say anything about that. It's a
very important hormone. Yeah. And so,
um, instead of going and getting
prescription injections, you do this
yourself, right? And you're going to
lose, you know, quarter of a pound, half
a pound, 2 lbs a day, depending on how
you are with that portion control piece,
right? And just like you said, Aaron
lost 100 pounds. We have thousands of
people every month. I see. It's amazing.
It's absolutely amazing. And I see it
around the world. People are just this
product's going around the world now.
And you But even they're adding years to
their life. They're decreasing the
likelihood of arthritis and degenerative
diseases and cancer, god forbid, cancer,
heart disease, all that. All that
absolutely and um it's a combination of
the 90 essential nutrients, the Alex
pack is a combination
of um the uh super juices that's in the
BTT, the Beyond Tangerine, 115 super
juices, uh antioxidants fending off the
bad guys, magnesium. Well, it's all in
there. Yeah. Well, the osteo the the
Osteo FX Plus, we haven't even talked
about that one. That's wonderful
product. Yeah. Yeah. It's all in there.
And so any rate um obesity goes away
very quickly. Um but when you say uh
right now they're predicting 50% obesity
by the year 2030, that tells you that
they don't know what to do because if
they knew what to do, they say, "Okay,
right now we're 36% obesity. Here's what
we do. By 2030, it's going to be 20%."
They have no earthly idea because their
their theory has failed them. And they
cannot believe it's a disease of
deficiency. And their little pea brains
that cannot believe that it's a disease
of deficiency. Well, they're still
operating that steam engine mentality
where you put the coal in and you get a
fire and they don't understand that the
body is not a steam engine. There's a
whole it's it's a metabolic system. It's
a chemistry system. Okay. Now, the
spin-off of that, of course, they say
that people who are obese, they have a
higher rate of diabetes. Diabetes. Yep.
That's that's this sort of cousin
disease here. They run together, but not
all the time. You can have people who
are obese don't have diabetes, but they
do tend to run together. And we've known
for 70 years that that diabetes, type
two diabetes, which makes up 98% of the
diabetic population, is a simple mineral
deficiency disease. Again, it's not
genetic in any way, shape, or form. It
is not genetic in any way, shape, or
form for emphasis, right? It it is a
simple mineral deficiency disease. And I
have to tell you the story. You will
appreciate this pharmacist, man. There's
a fell out there by the name of Jerry
Murphy. He's he's an owner of one of the
largest um I think it's the third
largest um medical laboratory in
America. He services 7,000 hospitals and
tens of thousands of doctors private
offices every day with his medical
laboratory. This guy's got three
diagnostic like a diagnostic laboratory.
Yeah. They take specimens and send them
to the laboratory. They send the results
back to the doctor. Right. I mean this
guy has three Phit has three PhDs.
Oh yeah. He had terrible, brittle
diabetes. I mean, his blood sugar is off
the chart, even with injectable insulin,
and he knows about all this stuff. Well,
he has access to the finest
endocrinologist, the cutting edge of
research on what you do for diabetes,
all the drugs. I mean, he knows
everything about diabetes, the medical
system knows. Well, mutual friend
introduces us and because they've been
talking about diabetes for 25, 30 years,
right? And so, I said, "Well, yes, sir,
I can help you. I can I can get your A1C
hemoglobin down below five within a
couple of months. I can get your blood
sugar down below 100 without medication.
You'll be an
ex-diabetic. And he looks at me like,
"Oh, yeah, right. Right." He says, "Who
are you?" So, I had to introduce myself
a little bit. He said, "Well, I don't
believe you." So, tell you what, give,
you know, give me a test. I mean, um,
give it a try. You have everything to
gain, nothing to lose. You're not being
successful at what you're doing. He
said, "Okay, I'll give you 90 days,
Wall." He says, "If you can get my A1C
hemoglobin down from 8.9 down below five
within 90 days, if you can get my blood
sugar consistently down below 100
without medication within 90 days, I'll
be your best friend." Wow. I'll fly
around my jet plane. I will show up
spontaneously, meetings, you won't even
know. I'll disappear and give my
testimony. I will brag about you. I will
put every one of my employees on your
program and I'll stop all my insurance.
And you knew you could do it. You knew I
was selfinsure. I've been doing it every
day for 35 years. And so he says, "But
I'll tell you what. If you fail, if in
90 days you haven't gotten rid of my
diabetes, I will hire somebody whose
only job is to go around every place
where you're going to give a talk and
tell everybody in the newspapers and
interview have be interviewed and tell
everybody what a quack you are, right?"
I said, "Okay, Jerry, let's do it. Let's
go for it." And he was kind of shocked
that I didn't want to negotiate, right?
And equivocate. He I said, "Let's do
it." Well, to make a long story short,
in two months time, following exactly
what I told him to do, and he was very
good. He was impeccable and doing
exactly what I told him. His A1C
hemoglobin dropped from 8.9 down to 4.3
and his blood sugar went down to 62
without medication. That's amazing. And
you know what? It's you. The way you put
it and the way you uh frame it, it's
easy. It's easy. And I want everybody to
understand this is easy. If you have
diabetes, if you have a blood sugar
problem and you've been told you're
going to be on insulin the rest of your
life and you're going to be on drugs the
rest of your life, this is easy because
it's a metabolic problem and once you
change your body's chemistry, it can't
help but follow. Now, uh that gets us to
what I my personal favorite product and
you know, we all have our favorite
products, but my personal favorite
product is the sweeties and that's
because that's the secret sauce. That's
the secret sauce, right? It's type two
diabetes. chromium and the venadium. And
these two minerals are so amazing for
blood sugar. Real quick, if you could
just tell the listeners a little bit
about chro chromium especially, but a
little bit about venadium. Well, these
two minerals have been known again for
70 years to uh support your body's
ability to metabolize carbohydrates and
fats and and sugars at the cellular
level, support healthy blood sugar by
sensitizing your cell membranes to
insulin. That's what they do. there
there's sort of the co-actor necessary
so your cell wall can recognize insulin
so it can speak the language of insulin.
People who have type two diabetes
contrary to what doctors tell their
patients when you have type two diabetes
you're making as much as 10 times more
insulin than a non-diabetic resistance
to the insulin. Exactly. So the insulin
levels going up because your body keeps
trying keep pumping out more saying why
aren't you responding? That's because
you're missing that key. It's it's kind
of like the combination uh on a
combination lock. And if you take this
along with the 90 essential nutrients by
themselves, you'll get okay results. But
if you take those two by themselves,
you'll be unhappy. Well, that wall thing
didn't work. You must take them along
with the 90s essential nut vitamins, the
vitamin C, all 90th century. In their
theory, you know what I'm saying? In
their theory, obesity is caused from
lack of exercise and a disease of
excess. You're eating too much. Right.
Because they think that we're like an
oven. They think if you eat
carbohydrates, it only 4.5 calories in
calories out. Exactly. 4.5 calories per
gram as opposed to nine calories per
gram for fat. You can't buy fat. It's
fat free, low fat, no fat, but we're
still fat. We're still obese. Okay? And
that's because it is not a disease of
excess and it's not a disease of lack of
exercise. When you're obese or even
overweight, it's a disease of
deficiency. You're deficient in a couple
of minerals. So, obesity is actually a
deficiency disease. Yes. Obesity
deficiency is a disease of a couple of
minerals. All right. And the symptom of
the deficiency these couple of minerals
is the munchies. Ah, so you can cure the
munchies by using these. Oh, yeah.
Uhhuh. So, what are the minerals? Well,
I won't tell you yet.
Tell everybody. What I want them to do
is get that book, Hell's Kitchen, and
read the whole story. Okay. So, it's
just a couple of minerals that will take
care of the munchies. Well, it's a Well,
there's two minerals that if you have
those a deficiency, those two minerals,
you're going to be one of these people
who weigh 600, 800, 1200 lb. But any
mineral deficiency, not vit vitamin, you
can be a deficient all the vitamins you
want and you won't gain weight. Huh?
It's mineral deficiency. some mineral
deficiencies in horses. It's called
cribbing. They chew on the fence, right?
How about pika? Is that what pika is?
PA. Yeah. And little kids will eat dirt
and stuff like that. Y it's because of
mineral deficiency. Huh. Only. So when
people have the munchies, their body is
in it's the body's wisdom is let's go
get some minerals and they're trying to
trying to find these minerals. You're
driving you to eat something to find the
minerals. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So
using the mighty 90 and using these
minerals will take care of the munchies
and take care of the weight loss.
Suddenly now, if you just get on the
Alex pack, take the 90s essential
nutrients, you'll lose 10, 15, 20 pounds
in a month. We see this all the time
without even thinking. Because suddenly
now your portions are automatically get
smaller because you're tired of throwing
food away. Yeah. And you're not going to
eat between meals. You'll you'll take
some snacks and think, you know, I'm I
don't even know why I took this. I'm not
even really that hungry, but out of
habit, you're doing it. And it doesn't
take you long to figure out I don't need
to do this anymore. So dieting isn't
even hard once once you get the
nutrients that you need. I wouldn't even
use that term. Yeah. What I would do is
talk about portion control as opposed to
dieting, right? Because you don't even
have to think about portion control
because when the pah and the and the
munchies goes away, portion control is
just sort of self regulating. Right now,
to speed it up, we have actually have
what we call the cylinder effect weight
management system, which has a meal
replacer in it, uh, which is 80 calories
and and no sugar. So, it's great for
diabetics who need to lose weight. It's
only 80 calories. You could have two of
those meals a day. Hey, I like to throw
in a couple of eggs uh and make it with
water. You're only going to get like a
250 calorie meal. So, two of those is
500 calories. You're going to have a 300
or 500 calorie meal. You're down below
1,000 calories. And you have all your
nutrients. You have all your nutrients,
right? Because you're still going to
take your 90 essential nutrients. You're
going to take your Alex back even though
you've cut your calories. Your portion
controls way down here, but you you're
still taking your 90 essential nutrients
and you're going to lose weight. We see
it all the time. In fact, that's the
most dramatic example of how powerful
this stuff is is the weight loss. And
the weight loss isn't even shouldn't
even necessarily be the target of what
you're looking for. That's like an it
just happens. It happens on it. Now, if
somebody needs to lose 25, 50, 75, 100
pounds or more, then we throw in what we
call ASAP. I like to add ASAP. ASAP is
an acronym for as slim as possible.
Right. But I like to say ASAP. ASAP
because it's as slim as possible. As
soon as possible. Yeah. Now. Exactly.
And so, um, what I like to do if you
need to lose 50 pounds or less, you put
one dropper full under your tongue. um
of this liquid what it is it's it's
amino acids which is the raw material
for your pituitary to make certain
hormones like growth hormone. No, like
HC. Oh, H Oh, okay. All right. All
right. And so don't tell anybody. I
don't say anything about that. It's a
very important hormone. Yeah. And so, um
instead of going and getting
prescription injections, you do this
yourself, right? And you're going to
lose, you know, quarter of a pound, half
a pound, two pounds a day, depending on
how you are with that portion control
piece, right? And just like you said,
Aaron lost 100 pounds. We have thousands
of people every month. I see. It's
amazing. It's absolutely amazing. And I
see it around the world. People are just
this product's going around the world
now. And you But even but they're adding
years to their life. They're decreasing
the likelihood of arthritis and
degenerative diseases and cancer, God
forbid, cancer, heart disease, all that.
All that. Absolutely. And um it's a
combination of the 90th essential
nutrients, the Alex pack. is a
combination of um the uh super juices
that's in the BTT, the Beyond Tangerine,
115 super juices, uh antioxidants,
fending off the bad guys, magnesium,
well, it's all in there. Yeah. Well, the
osteo the the osteo effects plus we
haven't even talked about that one.
That's wonderful part. Yeah. Yeah, it's
all in there. And so any rate, um
obesity goes away very quickly. Um, but
when you say, uh, right now they're
predicting 50% obesity by the year 2030,
that tells you that they don't know what
to do. Because if they knew what to do,
they say, "Okay, right now we're 36%
obesity. Here's what we do. And by 2030,
it's going to be 20%." They have no
earthly idea because their their theory
has failed them. And they cannot believe
it's a disease of deficiency. And their
little pea brains cannot believe that
it's a disease of deficiency. Well,
they're still operating that steam
engine mentality where you put the coal
in, you get a fire. And they don't
understand that the body is not a steam
engine. There's a whole it's it's a
metabolic system. It's a chemistry
system. Okay. Now, the spin-off of that,
of course, they say that people who are
obese, they have a higher rate of
diabetes. Diabetes. Yep. That's that's
this sort of cousin disease here. They
run together, but not all the time. You
can have people who are obese don't have
diabetes, but they do tend to run
together. And we've known for 70 years
that that diabetes, type two diabetes,
which makes up 98% of the diabetic
population, is a simple mineral
deficiency disease. Again, it's not
genetic in any way, shape, or form. It
is not genetic in any way, shape, or
form for emphasis, right? It it is a
simple mineral deficiency disease. And I
have to tell you the story. You will
appreciate this pharmacist, man. There's
a fellow out there by the name of Jerry
Murphy. He's he's an owner of one of the
largest um I think it's the third
largest um medical laboratory in
America. He services 7,000 hospitals and
tens of thousands of doctors private
offices every day with his medical
laboratory. This guy's got three
diagnostic like a diagnostic
laboratories. Yeah. They take specimens
and send them to the laboratory. They
send the results back to the doctor.
Right. I mean this guy has three ph
literally he has three PhDs.
Oh yeah. He had terrible brittle
diabetes. I mean his blood sugar is off
the chart even with injectable insulin
and he knows about all this stuff. Well,
he has access to the finest
endocrinologist, the cutting edge of
research and what you do for diabetes,
all the drugs. I mean, he knows
everything about diabetes and medical
system knows. Well, mutual friend
introduces us. And because they've been
talking about diabetes for 25, 30 years,
right? And so I said, "Well, yes, sir. I
can help you. I can I can get your A1C
hemoglobin down below five within a
couple of months. I can get your blood
sugar down below 100 without medication.
You'll be an
ex-diabetic." And he looks at me like,
"Oh, yeah, right. Right." He says, "Who
are you?" So, I had to introduce myself
a little bit. He said, "Well, I don't
believe you." So, tell you what, give,
you know, give me a test. I mean, um,
give it a try. You have everything to
gain, nothing to lose. You're not being
successful at what you're doing. He
said, "Okay, I'll give you 90 days."
Wall. He says, "If you can get my A1C
hemoglobin down from 8.9 down below five
within 90 days, if you can get my blood
sugar consistently down below 100
without medication within 90 days, I'll
be your best friend." Wow. I'll fly
around my jet plane. I will show up
spontaneous, meaning you won't even
know. I'll disappear and give my
testimony. I will brag about you. I will
put every one of my employees on your
program and I'll stop all my insurance.
And you knew you could do it. You knew
you I was self-insure. Well, I've been
doing it every day for 35 years. And so
he said, "But I'll tell you what, if you
fail, if in 90 days you haven't gotten
rid of my diabetes. I will hire somebody
whose only job is to go around every
place where you're going to give a talk
and tell everybody in the newspapers and
interview have be interviewed and tell
everybody what a quack you are." Right?
I said, "Okay, Jerry, let's do it. Let's
go for it." He was kind of shocked that
I didn't want to negotiate, right? And
equivocate. He I said, "Let's do it."
Well, to make a long story short, in two
months time, following exactly what I
told him to do, and he was very good. He
was impeccable and doing exactly what I
told him, his A1C hemoglobin dropped
from 8.9 down to 4.3 and his blood sugar
went down to 62 without medication.
That's amazing. And you know what? It's
you, the way you put it and the way you
uh frame it, it's easy. It's easy. And I
want everybody to understand this is
easy. If you have diabetes, if you have
a blood sugar problem and you've been
told you're going to be on insulin the
rest of your life and you're going to be
on drugs the rest of your life, this is
easy because it's a metabolic problem
and once you change your body's
chemistry, it can't help but follow.
Now, uh that gets us to what I my
personal favorite product and you know,
we all have our favorite products, but
my personal favorite product is the
sweeties. And that's because that's the
secret sauce. That's the secret sauce,
right? type, the chromium and the
venadium. And these two minerals are so
amazing for blood sugar. Real quick, if
you could just tell the listeners a
little bit about chro chromium
especially, but a little bit about
venadium. Well, these two minerals have
been known again for 70 years to uh
support your body's ability to
metabolize carbohydrates and fats and
and sugars at the cellular level,
support healthy blood sugar by
sensitizing your cell membranes to
insulin. That's what they do. They're
there sort of the co-actor necessary so
your cell wall can recognize insulin so
it can speak the language of insulin.
People who have type two diabetes
contrary to what doctors tell their
patients when you have type two diabetes
you're making as much as 10 times more
insulin than a non-diabetic resistance
to the insulin. Exactly. So the insulin
levels going up because your body keeps
trying keep pumping out more saying why
aren't you responding? That's because
you're missing that key. It's it's kind
of like the combination uh on a
combination lock. And if you take this
along with the 90 essential nutrients by
themselves, you'll get okay results. But
if you take those two by themselves,
you'll be unhappy. Say, "Well, that wall
thing didn't work." You must take them
along with the 90 essential B vitamins,
the vitamin C, all 90, right? All the
amino acids, I mean, everything. You
cannot do it in an isolated way. That's
right. That's right. Okay. I don't want
to get people get the impression they
can just take those two minerals and
their diabetes. No, no, no. Those are
the secret sauce that goes along with
the basic program and then it will work
every time. There's there's actually a
component in the body called the glucose
tolerance factor which chromium and and
I I think venadium might be part of are
part of that glucose tolerance. But then
it's something your body puts together
when you have those nutrients, right?
Just like your bones. What's what's the
secret sauce for bones? Well, minerals
including phosphorus and calcium.
Magnesium. Well, no. Your bones require
all 90 essential nutrients essential.
Exactly. So, if you just take calcium,
you'll still get osteoporosis and
fractures and arthritis. That's such an
important point. You can't say that
enough. It is the entire spectrum of
essential nutrients. And that's why the
term the mighty 90 is so important. It's
not just one nutrient. As important as
chromium is and as important as venadium
is and as important as calcium is, it's
the entire spectrum of nutrients that
you need. You cannot make an angel food
cake. Yeah. With McCormix liquid vanilla
extract by itself, right? You can get an
angel food crepe as you said. Well, you
wouldn't even get a crepe but just the
the extract, right? But um nobody we can
we can make a town diabetes free in 60
days. Isn't that amazing? Diabetes is
probably one of the easiest things to
treat, one of the easiest things to
reverse. And you know what's interesting
is you could be a hero so fast when you
tell when you get people like like this
guy you're talking about, Jerry, you can
be a hero so fast simply by putting
people on these these kinds of essential
nutrients. And how many people how much
death and destruction and dis and just
nightmares does something like diabetes
cause in this country? Well, next
obesity is the biggest single cause
factor in medicine today. One-third of
Americans, 30% of Americans have type
two diabetes. And how many
pre-diabetics? Well, that's scary, isn't
it? Another one-third. Right. So, you're
talking twothirds of a country that
spends more money than any other. All n
No, no. All nations combined. Combined.
Right. We are the we we spend more money
than any other country in the history of
the planet. All nations combined. Not
any country. All nations ever in
history. And we are the sickest culture
in the history of the planet. And
something as simple as supplementing
with nutrition, making sure that you're
eating correctly, staying away from the
bad things. Staying away from the bad
things can make such a huge difference.
It's been such an honor to talk to you.
I can't even tell you. Doc Well, thank
you so so much. Thank you for not just
for me, but thank you on behalf of
everybody that you've touched and
everybody whose lives you've improved,
everybody whose lives you changed.
You're just an amazing amazing amazing
human being and it's a pleasure. Well, I
appreciate you for this. has been a I
really appreciate you because 15 years
ago you don't tell about my pants. Don't
tell you came to me and you said I I
really want to learn from you how to use
nutrition to help my patients and people
I know and you kept your word and I'm
very proud of you for that. Thank you. I
appreciate it. Well, that's all the time
we have for today. Thank you so much
everybody. It's been a pleasure and an
honor. I'm far Doc Wallik. Thanks a lot
buddy. We'll talk again.